[Music]
in 3d sushi news yeah mine's always 2d I
don't know where you guys are eating
submitted by this boba slaps I know
Dobis slaps is it like a new new
terminology it's been around this Bobby
slap the beep slapped yeah I heard that
one yeah same thing it's the same thing
a new restaurant will serve 3d printed
sushi based on the customers biological
samples in the restaurant I'm not come
you take a spit in and they make sushi
out of that you're only missing one more
hair follicles skin peep what they make
out of your pee so it would like it
ordered nutrition like you're missing
this out of your nutrition how are you
so good that what it was that's exactly
what it was so this Japanese company is
fusing science and sushi to create
nutrient-rich foods based on the
individuals requirements really it's icy
yeah so they're saying that once you
making a reservation to of this
restaurant which will be opening in
Tokyo next year what I think you said
oldest Russian on that's gonna be
opening up in Tokyo when I see you
before that bed you're very beautiful
today I said that when you make your
reservation to this restaurant they will
burp on the envelope they will send you
this kit and you will have to submit a
biological samples of either your spit
your urine or your stool
oh yeah yeah good well your blood can
you just like send that they didn't
mention blood huh like how they give you
options you could spit oh [ __ ] or piss
I'm spitting dude I'm not
sit there with a cup in the below they
just try to [ __ ] it whatever they said
in small last give him the company still
shits in the envelope so weird so they
just tell you it's like well you have to
pee into this what are the options do
you have well you could just breathe
into this that's the first option you
[ __ ] if this is what the health
can't look funny you could either stick
this up your ass or breathe into this -
it's called sushi singularity I would do
all the wrong ones in the wrong ones
I'll spit in the [ __ ] container
[Laughter]
should've the [ __ ] and sir I would like
to let you know that you should probably
go to your dentist you know it was
actually the word and not or so you have
to submit all these oh that makes sense
that makes sense wait collected they
make a sushi no just this [ __ ] that
you're missing your sushi maker has to
look at all the [ __ ] and piss no I'm
pretty sure their sign is Chevy's like
okay I'll take some time though like
what if you change your diet up and then
by the time you get there it's like you
don't need this [ __ ] no that's true I
don't know what the time for you to
spend [ __ ] again I feel like most people
though if they're deficient in something
there's a reason why they are for that
long so they probably don't have that
regularly in their diet I just picture
this [ __ ] Japanese sushi chef just
getting assembly goes let me show you
guys a video clip because this is to
show you on command they're using food
gel to create these you should jail jail
jail I said gel really worried
it's gel GTL no the foods are
he just shot in a [ __ ] car or you
come to this bit what what is that your
probably looks nothing like that in the
lab oh sure it does
it's the sushi chef tasting everything
this is what they are saying it's gonna
look like so they're just giving you
vitamins wait what
top sisters I do need some lotion on his
face you with your hands that's the
right right way to eat it now I'm okay
off of that that does not look tasty
where's a good sushi cig I'm down down
give me what I'm lacking say does it
taste good what does it taste like I
don't know if I only have to eat it once
I'm down what if it tastes good and you
want more yeah I mean I've done it like
what if it's like the most like amazing
thing that your body has been meeting in
this world wonder if it's one cue or
it's like until you're full I think this
is one it's like a rotating thing you
know I know so they're they're pretty
much trying to push the future of food
and 3d printing food that's crazy and so
the thing is called open meals their
company and in their website they also
have like the future section and they're
projecting all the way until 2100 I was
like what the future is gonna look like
for food and in one of them it says
something like they'll have we'll all in
our homes have our own 3d printers oh my
god it's the [ __ ] Jetsons exactly
it's like that and so and then it will
get to the point where people will
create their own dishes online Oh like a
PDF yeah and then it is usable I'll get
into your machine that you have at home
and that's how every everyone's gonna
eat their meals that's amazing that's
[ __ ] if you want you could be Steve
trying to cook and you could make a
perfect meal at a time all I want is
that Back to the Future Pizza yeah you
put that and it goes that's all I was
thinking that Wow yeah how much does it
cost
I don't know they don't they so they
they just announced this recently at the
South by Southwest and they're just
saying that they're gonna open this
restaurant where are they opening it Oh
Tokyo next year I want to go
want to try this well I want the one
that's in the house because like now I
have a option of something nutritious
and something that maybe I need that's
custom and I can hit that button and I
can eat it and leave having to be
creative every single time the house won
they're projecting that to come and to
in 2040 when I'm almost dead so for this
restaurant you have to submit your
samples of poo and pee and everything
and then make a reservation 20 years
yeah once you make that reservation ship
I need nutrients now so I can live to
that age yeah they're calling it so like
they're saying by 2030 there will be
this online food data plan yeah so
they're pretty much saying that they'll
be this online platform kinda like
social media for our lives it'll be like
a social media kind of thing for food
recipes and stuff yeah cuz like on Etsy
so I got a sticker maker and I like to
mix stickers it's like I'm obsessed with
making stickers right now but like if I
get too lazy and I'm like I wish someone
already made this sticker you could
actually go on Etsy and you download
like plans and it's already that's
called the cut files and people already
design the stickers and I just
downloaded it and then my machine knows
what to do from that cut file yeah let's
do Co machine
yeah it's dough do you put the stickers
I put them in my planner yeah so it's
like to do or like birthday know like
doctor's appointment yeah it's so fun
yeah they're also projecting to have
this like in hospitals for people that
need nutrients and stuff that's so they
can have what I'm sayin
yeah they're projecting that by 2023 you
know what they should do is hook up this
[ __ ] to your bathroom and then like
every time you're about to [ __ ] or
whatever you put your
name in kind of like how they could
youcould personal life scales or
whatever you sit down and then they just
take samples of your store as things go
and then boom what you're missing today
is iron this and this and this don't
take my eye to you or think it's like an
inventively I know that's true oh you
know how they're they're making me in a
lab now I wonder if they'll have like a
meat gel that's not made from like an
animal and then I wonder if you're pro
tied yeah would actually eat me
projecting that in 2028 they'll have a
dull have this type of program and food
like creating food for diverse food
parties yeah so let's say like someone
who is Muslim or on a diet or vegan or
lactose intolerant
but removing the things that they can't
eat like substituting it but it's like
the same plate yeah whatever it is that
you're trying to order and like you can
share that that's crazy
but with accommodating to your dietary
restrictions I wonder if it's like you
get this it's like a ink cartridge right
that's full of like vitamins and
nutrients it's like this but then
there's also a flavor cartridge yeah how
are you gonna make it taste good
yeah just a bunch of essential [ __ ] and
we have gels food gels gel right now
yeah crazy so I guess they have like a
fish gel and a rice gel and then they
put it together yeah that's gonna be
artificial that's just a regular food
man me too that's right I just like some
regular exact care bar we go have you
been to Bazaar mm-hmm yo-yo ma to the
bazaar or they make all those gastric
acid jestro gastral the form thing yeah
yeah yeah they like food astronomy and
they do like like they'll have like a
Philly cheesesteak but like this it'll
be like made out of like water or like
it's like but it melts in your mouth
it's weird if I do control your ear
cheese yeah
Chili's like all that other things
Alucard
but yeah it's like with salt foam salt
air I I don't want to say I hate it but
it's more like it's an interesting
experience I don't want that I want food
yeah you're always hungry after we
always go to Taco Bell every time we've
gone there I mean I've only been there
like three times but that's a lot of
time yeah it's like four birthdays but
they'll do that right so you'll get food
and they'll go okay this is what I'm
gonna do I want you to eat this piece of
salmon right but I'm a burn this hay and
then put it all over your face you see
that smoke what the [ __ ] man just give
me my food right but they burned the hay
around it and I'm like I don't I don't
need all this just what is it supposed
to taste like cuz I feel like food
already there's so much stuff that can
be done to it I just [ __ ] just do that
[ __ ] right I'm not about it's simply
about the experience you want cuz if you
like want the food for you're like a
foodie I don't think that that would be
the place for you
if you're just like oh this is weird and
we're gonna eat it oh my god it does
taste like a sandwich I think if it's
like if it's kind of like going to a
theme park yeah that's cool yeah you
know I mean like we're Bart's birthday
how it was like that where there was
like very gimmicky yeah yeah yeah yeah
the gimmick is that it's like air food
yeah yeah yeah you're like wow it kind
of tea look small readings and popcorn
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]